[Music]
what are the strengths the blockchain
technology the strengths are that we can
take many business processes today and
and by business processes you might even
include land titles and buying and
selling a home right you might include
providence tracking of products you know
diamonds and food supply that sort of
thing one of the real strengths is being
able to take these systems that today
depend very much on bureaucracy and
paperwork and very human processes for
sure but processes that get bogged down
and and actually automate them and cut
the cost of a lot of this but also by
automating them improve the audibility
audits ability of them right people pay
a lot of money to have third-party
auditors come in and make sure that the
claims that are in their books are
actually real right it's a tremendous
burden and it's why bureaucracy often
requires three signatures to do anything
you interesting right to send a shipping
container for example from Asia to the
United States about half the cost of
that is in the paperwork involved in
coordinating between twenty to thirty
different organizations that for sign
off from the Bill of Materials all the
way to the person that's delivered to
right if blockchain technology can help
us automate these systems make them more
efficient
they may also ensure that we keep the
opportunities for fraud and the
opportunities for corruption to a
minimum right if we make it hard to
steal people's land or to ship illicit
product in in shipping containers right
or simply in approving a permit for
construction on your home holding that
up for days or months until you pay me
an expediter fee right which all too
often happens in in in home remodeling
if we can make these processes a bit
more automated more transparent than
then I think we can do a lot to improve
society in these in these ways and that
kind of wraps together two or three
different advantages of this the other
advantage is it's a fun space to be and
there's a lot of dynamic thinking going
on a lot of new companies a lot of
technologies talking about very far off
concepts and it's finally a place to get
people excited about technology
especially as it's so much about
decentralization right what are the
challenges one of the challenges right
now for sure is that it's early days
with the tech
ecology there are a couple of places
where there's clearly a lot of value
being created there's clearly a lot of
activity say in the cryptocurrency space
but in many ways again like the early
days of the web we don't yet know what
the big winners will be and that from
the technology right but we know that
that this is something everybody will
need in one way or another so the
challenge right now is there's a lot of
options and many of them are fairly
amateur when it comes to actually
building and running them for big
systems that's one reason we've chosen a
hyper ledger to focus on what are the
simplest things we can do now and ship
out as product that people can use right
that they can actually run and the
second thing is really understanding
that and this is really hard for many
industries and many actors in industries
that you know every use case I could
give you around where blockchain
technology is applicable you could
always come back to me as a technologist
and say wouldn't this be more efficient
faster cheaper to do as a central
database right isn't somebody just gonna
pull a Google or pull an Amazon and
build a central database to track all
the fish supply caches and shipping you
know this or that and the answer is
always yes that it is more efficient and
cheaper but it's also expensive when you
think about the cost of having
politically and from a business
perspective having a central actor in a
marketplace right many marketplaces
simply don't want that right the banks
of the world don't want one big bank at
the center right people who care about
their land title right care about worry
about the corruptibility of of the land
title office in certain countries you
know that's a big issue blockchain
technology allows us to build these same
kind of systems but in a world where we
don't want to or we can't trust central
actors and that's hard to wrap your head
around especially because everyone
believes they can be trusted right hey
if I'm the center of a market you can
trust me what do you mean you can't try
it feels like a very personal affront
perhaps even to say that but I it's
essential I think to realizing how you
can't really grow your market beyond
those who can really trust you if that's
your business model right so I that's
that's I think hard for people for some
people to get the conceptual model
around just
like it might have been hard in 1993 to
understand what it means to send email
to somebody at the other end of the
other side of the planet or to buy a
television you know or buy a car through
a website right you would have been told
you were crazy to think that people
would be doing that in 1993 now we kind
of take it almost for granted so that's
these are the the challenges but I see
many people addressing these challenges
but most recently I was a venture
capitalist and so I looked at a lot of
different companies including companies
in the Bitcoin space and increasing
their the blockchain space and I was
kind of bored by all the examples I was
given until I saw one company approached
us and talked about land titles and
emerging markets right land titles why
would that be interesting well there's a
economist named Hernando de Soto who
wrote a book the wealth at the bottom of
the pyramid who talked about how in many
countries citizens don't have title to
the land that they might have been
living on for generations right we're a
title is something we understand as you
know a set of documents recorded at a at
a County Registrar or at a government
office that allow us to prove not only
to somebody we're hoping to sell some
property to that we actually own it but
also prove to a mortgage lender that we
have this property and you know we'd
like a loan and if we fail to pay the
loan then they get the property right
that's something that many people in the
emerging markets do not have access to
it we have not right so many countries
started to digitize and introduce land
titling systems and realize they had a
problem where if that was digital it was
also very easy for somebody to corrupt
right so it is easy for a government
bureaucrat
to who desired a piece of property
perhaps for their son you know to have
some beachfront property north of the
Capitol or because an oil company wanted
to come in and drill right it was pretty
easy for them to step in and erase all
history of somebody's ownership of
property in a way that because it's
digital disappears forever in a way that
even when something's paper yes you can
set fire to a paper record but it's
actually really hard to completely
eliminate a rich paper trail in
something like land title so this is a
problem and the solution to that problem
that this company had come up with was
to implement a
and tidal system as a distributed ledger
right as a database but one that is
shared immediately every time something
is recorded into this database shared
with a large circle of other companies
and agencies and NGOs that act as
witnesses for that transaction and if
somebody's land was taken away from them
a you know would be noticed very quickly
right that person would have a history
of what happened on that property and
they'd be able to see that immediately
but B if their signature wasn't on the
right document it wouldn't even be
accepted as a transaction on that
Network so land titling you know there
and the reason I bring it up here is
this is interesting when you're talking
about a country like Honduras or the
Republic of Georgia or Estonia like
other countries that have started to
adopt this for economic development
reasons but think about the mortgage
crisis in 2008 all right part of the
reason why for any of you who have seen
the movie the Big Short
you remember these scenes of panic
selling of these instruments which were
tranches of risk in the mortgage
industry where nobody really had a clear
understanding of what the underlying
assets were the houses and the mortgages
that pointed to those houses who owned
the paperwork for those mortgages who
owned the title on those homes this was
data that was lost inside of these
bureaucracies that didn't have the
manpower to respond to the queries and
in many cases it you ended up with
people selling assets for pennies on the
dollar and for people with homes with 95
percent paid off mortgages getting
eviction notices from somebody who owned
less than a percent of the interest in
that mortgage all of this to say there
are many people who who believe that if
blockchain technology had been
implemented at the beginning of the
2000s for the land title and mortgage
industry not only would you have had the
data there to understand who owned these
assets but those mortgages had if they
had been built as smart contract systems
and those tranches of risk as smart
contract systems that unwinding process
where everybody felt like they needed to
move out of that asset it might have
been a more orderly programmatic here's
all the data here's how it plays out now
we don't have to sell it for pennies on
the dollar we can sell it for ten
percent off of the price that we thought
it was actually worth and that might
have saved a lot of people's homes
avoided a lot of real friction in the
market but also a lot of the volatility
that we saw
and so the opportunity for distributed
Ledger's to both give us new
capabilities but also help us with
auditing help us with the stability of
markets even in scenarios where Trust is
really at a premium that's that's the
real potential here and these that might
sound like back-office or science
fiction kind of scenarios but i but i
but that's what's driving a tremendous
amount of interest in the industry today
[Music]